From the magical mind of J.K Rowling
and the magical wallet of a Harry Potter Global Franchise Development Team
comes a movie based on
a real fake textbook
based on a fake real textbook.
briefly mentioned in real Harry Potter books
Boy
We are really scraping the bottom of the barrel here, aren't we?
Fantastic Beast and Where to Find Them
Long after J.K ran out of novels,
the world still craves more Potter
But Hermione is way too famous these days (seriously?)
Harry is literally farting around
*Farting noise*
And Ron is...
where is Ron doing anyway?
Now
Get ready for a five-part prequel
that isn't off to the best start
but who cares, men?
that's part of heads need to fix
Ahhhhh
Uhhh
Nevermind.
Maybe I'll go find my patronus again
Look!
I'm a salmon!
That's...¿cool?
Journey.
To the upthight repressed society
at 1920's  New York
But beneath the surface
lies a magical world
That's also a really uptighted repress
They got their own non-creative slang
-The No-Maj
-The what?
-No magic!
Their own muggle racism
-I know that you have a broader
backwords non-relationship
with no magic people.
And the own stains sponsores murder jacuzzis
Don't that look good.
Uhmmm
Can we go back to Hogwarts, please?
Once upon a time
JK Rowling insisted on only using
british actors
but now the franchise has come to America
and everyone
is still
british
like fancy lad
Newt Scamander
the latest of Eddie Redmayne's
whisper mumblers
Marlin's beard!
wouldn't that be nice professor
I will harvest that planet
Don't you think this is ok?
He may not be charming
He may not be popular
None on us really fit into school
but he is willing to lie
to save his pokemon
at the cost of human lives
Nothing in there is dangerous
Please don't hurt my creatures!
They aren't dangerous!
Leave his brain. Come on
The first symptom would be flames out of his anus
They aren't dangerous!
*Grasp*
Ahhh!
*Creature noises*
*Breaking glass*
They aren't dangerous!
Please, please. They are not dangerous!
Newt's not alone in the big city
Move over
Ron
Draco
Snape
and Hermione
Because there's a far less interesting
gang in town
Like
The boring Tina Goldstein
The psychic Betty Boop
Random Jhon boy family drama
and
the actually likeable Kowalski
A muggle
who steals the show just by
reacting to stuff
That guy's got great face
So come along in a story
that works well enough on its own
but isn't that promising
as an intro to a franchise
oh
because what a whole world look
growing up with Harry Potter
We all know what happens
when Jhonny Deep plays a pale weirdo.
and no one ever need to see that again
Good morning, star shine
The earth says "Hello!"
Starring
Eddie Redmayne talks to animals
The pillsbury O-face
True Auror season 2
Boremione
DTF Scott Fitzgerald
We need to talk about Creedence
Avada Kadeppra
And
Ahhh!
Fake Monsters
He Brought a Zoo
cockroach in teapot
Jee!
If only there were a magic spell
that could help you out in this situation!
Acchio!
Hey, screen junkies
want to know even more
about Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them?
Then click the box in the right
for our guide to all the easter eggs hidden in the movie
If you still feeling honest
click the box in the left to watch
another awesome Honest Trailer
Harry Potter, you must go to the shire
and become a Jedi Knight
so you can sit on the Iron Throne
Honest Trailers is filmed
in front of an adorable live audience
Farm fresh butt nuggets from sale at your mom's house
I like pineapples on pizza
I honestly don't even know what's in my sprite